foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's uh that's more hype than I've
given all day
yeah we uh have you been practicing your
dancing man we've done a lot of dancing
should we just do a quick little snap no
no no no no no not right now uh producer
Andy are we on the air are we live we
are live cool hey everyone it's been a
this is our last taping day of 2022.
yeah happy New Year and so we didn't
have a chance to test at lunch we had
all kinds of things happen so um is this
working okay this is all working well if
you can't hear us text us or check one
two hey everybody I'm Jason I'm Jocko
and welcome to the Kelly after party
where we're going to take you behind the
scenes of the music of the Kelly
Clarkson show and we're gonna have
drinks right uh let's get to that
cocktail yeah this is well set me up
with cocktail Hmm this beautiful drink
is called the nightmarg okay we're gonna
get to that a little bit right now
you're not following producer Andy
script Jocko karako so anyway for the
drink
all right today we're going to talk
about oh look at the way I'm pouring
that we have a few kaliokies coming up
we're going to talk about can't wait
Kelly's not going to be lurking in the
chat today so I can uh today's uh
today's theme is NDA it's called a
non-disclosure agreement and that's what
it stands for yeah and I don't know if
I've ever turned mine in so we're gonna
break uh you're gonna hear a lot of
things today that
um we'll see how it goes everyone signs
them nobody follows them right let's see
how it goes uh we're gonna talk about uh
Christmas isn't canceled just you which
I got I got to co-wrote with Kelly and
Jesse and I produced it and you played
on it yep we recorded it in the summer
and a fun little question we'll get that
oh okay let me just do one okay I wore
this beautiful sweater for today and I
wore it in the summer when we were
recording it
foreign
so again we didn't sound check so uh
text me with any sound issues but
welcome to Kelly okay after party look
for our drinks cheers if you have them
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
I still hear your voice in there
all right Jocko this was uh the last two
weeks were my cocktails and um I might
be known as a little bit of a
micromanager control freak so but I let
Jaco bring a cocktail today I'm a little
nervous what do you have well my friend
known as Mr Elixir handsome Mike Daze he
created this cocktail for us all right
and do we have the luxury up there
producer because I definitely wouldn't
be able to tell you this oh I like this
it's tequila it's aperol Triple Sec uh
it's got a little bit of orange a little
bit of uh aperol similar to Campari uh
Maraschino liqueur it's better if I look
on that TV yeah it kind of that's what I
told you in rehearsal Draco uh so it
kind of sounds like a tequila Negroni
yeah I'm feeling it well it is actually
delicious send us your pictures what
you're drinking at home
[Music]
um
#kelly after party for those pictures
wow that's actually and thank you Mr
Elixir yeah well cheers everybody thanks
for joining us um this is our third one
I can't believe they're still actually
letting us do this yeah it's wild 23.
just get weird and make a show yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna confess like I I don't
have you ever watched a full episode of
our Kelly Clarkson show
I mean I have to watch because I edit
things but yeah I'm a big fan yeah well
I'm gonna confess Jack and I laid in bed
maybe not no no we texted each other
while we were laying in bed
um separately and uh I've probably
watched the after party three or four
times I'm really enjoying doing this and
I'm thankful for that you guys are
enjoying it and uh just please let NBC
and everybody know that you're liking it
we have some shout outs today oh who are
we shouting well first of all I want to
shout out to our friends Jeremy and Pam
at Miss in the podcast I think has done
it but today is Jeremy's birthday or
maybe it's tomorrow either way let's do
it happy birthday
to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear Jeremy and miss
independence
that got to like Chuck E cheese speed
yeah well we have to I mean we got a
producer Andy's over there already
circling so we got to keep the suit on
um and we want to thank you uh last
episode we had a lot of concern for
Jocko
um I didn't let Jaco have any drinks
before this episode
a lot of people suggested that we
provide snacks for him yeah food to help
soak up the alcohol I'm hungry what do
you got a shout out to Ann Bradstreet
she sent us cookies
and and we were supposed to say for this
episode but we ate them all we literally
ate all of them
um but speaking of that shout out to
Emily and Destiny and Rhonda my wife who
are all watching it's funny like I don't
they've never had parties to watch the
show but they're having they're actually
getting together and watching the effort
and uh Destiny's remember is Jocko's
virtual breathalyzer so keep an eye on
him oh
this is Jacob uh Damon is that your it's
my friend okay
all right well leave us your questions
first in the comments and anything you'd
like to know when making Kelly Oakies to
ban the process we we actually have a
lot in store for you this episode and it
was so cool getting cookies and I also
really love chicken tendies that's what
I like to call them chicken tenders so
if you feel like sending chicken tenders
be be welcome to do that we will eat
them and we also have to Shout Out
director Sandy director Sandy's one of
our um we've seen her on tour for the
past 20
Jill Pickering sent me a YouTube video
on how to say tour so to director Sandy
watching from Canada thanks for watching
this and uh yeah just uh send us your
pictures at hashtag kalioki party how do
you say Australia I say Australia
Australia like you're awestruck for
Australia but do we have any comments
here we go Andy oh yeah
those live comments I have charged the
iPad this time
oh that's weird to see myself as we're
going into Christmas here uh the staff
the art department just brought by an
entire bottle oh shout out to the art
Department Emmy award-winning
executive showrunner she brought me a
lovely box of Robert Venable our
beautiful mixer said Jocko your mic is
distorting oh but that's because Jaco
doesn't listen to me and he's talking
like he's talking like this in the
microphone and I'm like I have a
compressor and everything on you so
chill out Jocko the first episode I was
told to speak closer to them I know but
I turned up the gain so you don't have
to do that I'm turning you down now all
right thank you Alex Duda and this came
from my assistant Claudine it's a lovely
gin made by grapes made with grapes not
by grapes
bummer
all right
Jaco you're being asked questions
OG said get Jocko some snacks he's
trying to eat the microphone send
tandies the people we actually do have a
question saying Jocko can you say your
Baseline please which is uh boom boom
karaoke after party which I failed this
one at the end of last episode Kelly
after party all right there's your
Baseline was that from Destiny I said
that a little sexy okay and I'm gonna
oh the Kelly Clarkson show wrote we do
want chicken we have our Christmas my
band y'all mug here
should we sell those we should but I
don't think we can it's a whole NBC
legal thing Integrations blah blah blah
if you want to buy a mug just let us
know
well this has been I feel like we say
this every week this has actually been a
really crazy week for us this was one of
the most special I mean we had it's been
all of our Christmas episodes we
um Kelly Kelly came down with covid
which was a surprise to all of us and so
we had to Pivot the what are I could
bore you for hours with what our staff
has to do whenever something like this
happens but we last minute scripting
last minute music
um even today we had um Kyle had to
leave last minute for a personal
emergency and Rachel my assistant
stepped in and not only played bass
today she ran uh the live Track Force
and Playback I had to leave to go up to
the editing Bay during a segment to go
take care of something Rachel ran the
whole show it's crazy we also had the
first lady and I was just chilling we
had a former First Lady Michelle Obama
and I don't I feel like that's our
biggest guest ever I don't know I well
yeah I don't want to I don't get deep
into politics but um people are very
polarized when it comes to presidents
and first ladies and I've heard and read
a lot of things on both sides Michelle
Obama was the most amazing kind like I
don't care what you think about the
politics or anything like that like just
what a presence she was such a cool mom
and a cool person on the show and that's
why we call her a powerful lady yes and
we uh if you were if you watch our last
episode you know that we very pedily
keep track of who acknowledges or not
and we got a nice way from the former
first lady yeah it was fantastic Jewel
yeah jewel was our very first I think
she was our very first non-kelly Kelly
Kelly it was a Julie Julio okay Julie
okay Julie okay that doesn't work um we
had to learn that that morning and wow
she was fantastic and what an honor to
play with her she sang amazing and you
know what I I played Jazz when I was in
college I was actually really into it
when I was in college but I I rarely get
to play jazz nowadays and playing that
and we did some other jazz songs with
Kelly as well it's so much fun and I'm
glad you have fun on Jazz because as as
choco knows and caught everybody to ban
knows jazz is not my thing I did not
grow with that and it's it's I struggle
and we're gonna get into that later on
and we're gonna talk about uh Kelly's
Christmas album yeah we had some amazing
Jazz numbers and we're gonna talk about
some of that process and guess so uh we
have a question from Dana
how did you eat meat DNA for Kelly uh
Jason I'd like to ask you how did you
meet and come to work for Kelly
I was hired by Randy Jackson
he was a judge on American Idol hmm
I'm trying to hold in a burp right now
and I couldn't think fast enough where
the mute button okay
quick trivia yep what other bands did
Randy Jackson play in I don't know but
he played in Journey which was the
coolest thing to me when I met him so
cool I I hate to repeat the story but I
I've for those of you haven't heard I
actually met Randy Jackson in Miami
um while playing a show and my brother
came out and he wanted to get a picture
of Beyonce yeah Stephen and
um
and so my brother wanted a picture of
Beyonce and we handed the hand of the
camera this guy it was Randy Jackson I
didn't know that at the time he took the
picture we ended up exchanging numbers
and he called me and he said hey he
actually said yo dog hey this is Randy
Jackson that's his signature literally
said yo dog and uh I'm on this TV show
American Idol and I have this kid Justin
Guarini
um he was the runner up on the show I
need you to put a band together and go
do Leno and you said no I said well I
hadn't I've been on tour I'd never
watched tour I never watched the show so
I I told Randy I'm sorry I've just taken
another gig I can't do that I called my
wife told her about it and she's like uh
you need to call him back and take that
show we voted for Kelly Clarkson this
most amazing show ever so I called Randy
back and I was actually hired to play
for Justin Guarini on Leno who did a
song called sorry and then Justin and
Kelly had a duet
um for the movie from Justin to Kelly
never seen it I've never seen it out of
pure loyalty to Kelly I sworn to Kelly
great podcast episode what if we watch
I'm never gonna watch
Kelly had a duet called Timeless and I
met Kelly and we talked about Texas and
she hired me forever and that's how I
met Kelly and Russ's history okay that
was a great long story thank you Dana
for that and I have a funny I'm trying
to pull it up on my phone okay
um this is a little fun thing but you
know how when you're in high school you
do like the yearbook photos and stuff
and you get voted for things
I didn't get voted most hot or prom king
or anything like that kill surprise but
I did get voted most likely to be on
American Idol and I I'm trying to pull
up the picture right now that makes me
feel so old in high school there wasn't
even American Idol for me to post where
we go from here producer Andy while
Jocko's looking for it oh I couldn't
reliving his Gloria days well keep your
questions
M Night Margaritas keeping watch and uh
we'll be doing a little Q and A later on
can we shout out to the room yeah shout
out to the room
come on get pumped yeah come on we need
more of a party in here
don't give away the secrets we have some
surprises coming up
all right we'll keep your questions
coming Dan Johnson said Jocko is like a
puppy LOL thanks Dan yeah I like it are
you saying I'm like cute like no like an
unpotty trained puppy that you have to
like look over your shoulder and make
sure the puppy is doing the right thing
every five minutes and Rue's in the room
hey Rue
Rue knows this room very intimately hey
Jason yeah what are we doing today uh
we're doing the Kelly o'kee after party
once again uh
okay we've had a couple of Great
Performances of the past week
um let's check them out well first of
all producer Andy wants me to show this
and we didn't have a lot of time to prep
this but
um apparently a lot of our staff is
obsessed with whatever is happening
um I don't have the picture but let's do
this
can you put us over on the uh the little
the QuickTime soon I think Alicia
Madigan said cute puppy
oh man yeah this is where technical
difficulties ensue anyway Jocko and I
had an amazing Alice said what guitar
does Jocko play
electric acoustic yeah I can't find it
anyway oh no we did it go to my
Instagram he'll pull up the socials
right now and you can see some pictures
we we uh we recorded a very special
performance of sisters from White
Christmas which I've never heard of
before it's airing Monday and I think
after this you can actually call me the
musical director and not the music
director because it's my first musical
performance Jason has always said I'm
not a musical guy as in musicals
Broadway Theater he said I'm a music
director correct yes because I don't
direct musically but now you have
directed a music call number yeah we had
a choreographer and everything and I
can't wait for you we're gonna we're
gonna break this down definitely at some
point I not only did we do the music I
had to five six seven eight tap tap
touch touch Vegas Vegas Vegas Alex just
came in the room yay Alex
[Applause]
thank you Alex for our lovely bottle of
wine we really appreciate it
yeah there's a photo we were looking for
right yes
all right Jocko Alex has a story Let's
uh let's give Alex a microphone
it's a private later story I'll tell you
later okay
that's good because our theme of the
show is ndas which are non-disclosure
agreements
yeah and so we're gonna we're gonna get
into um that's gonna tie in later on
sorry NBC standards and practice is so
nervous and Kelly Kimball's like
trembling a little bit I promise this
has a great payoff NDA non-disclosure
agreement um I I just have to add Alex
you walked in and there are so many
comments about you we love Alex Alex is
the legend hi Alex
it said did Alex's brother provide queso
oh
yes we're working on Kelly singing The
Baby song we're gonna pick it out and
we're gonna have queso it's gonna be
great queso and Tequila which we're
having have you tried our tequila
tonight
it's kind of like a tequila Negroni it's
called a night Mark Before Christmas
the nightmarg Before Christmas
all right well one of our favorite songs
this is a throwback to our last karaoke
after party we were talking about we had
Dwayne Johnson on the show slow Rock The
Rock and we had rehearsed it's reigning
men Hallelujah because Dwayne Johnson
likes to work out too it's raining men
and you were surprised by that I'm
surprised once again and I think that'd
be a good time to bring in we have
another special guest today Lester
Estelle our drummer is in the house come
on in come on in Lester are you here
Lester
uh Lester's Gonna Keep Us waiting oh
yeah it's all right you know he's having
a tough day he's been icing his arm yeah
we're gonna get into that too he played
a little too much drums today so uh yes
so we we rehearsed It's Raining Men and
we didn't do that because we pivoted
last minute pivot is the theme of season
four for the Kelly Clarkson show we are
pivot experts
um so we didn't do the song because we
uh Loretta Lynn passed away the day
before sadly and we decided to do a song
in honor of her yep and um but we
already rehearsed the song and it was
such a great arrangement we did it
I actually didn't realize till after I
was reading fan comments that Kelly
performed this on American Idol really
yeah because again I didn't I didn't
watch the show and um and so a lot of
people were comparing the side-by-side
performances
and it's amazing who wore it better uh
the 2022 Kelly would definitely wore it
better that's what I'm talking about
yeah I was telling her like I've never
I've never seen her not
like technically she sold it but somehow
it just wasn't it wasn't right at that
moment and 2022 Kelly oh my goodness
killed it I bet the American Idol
version was too long that was probably
oh it's Lester in the house
hey Lester how's your little arm doing
how's your little arm
take a mic Lester hey guys no I don't
yeah
I'm gonna try this Tequila drink oh no
yeah yeah hey let's get him a Tequila
drink anybody got some ice Celeste we're
reliving some memories we had Dwayne
Johnson on the show yes uh the rock who
you took a picture with him I think you
were kind of a fan I'm a huge fan yeah
unless there's a big workout guy so we
rehearsed It's Raining Men and we didn't
do that because of Loretta Lynn and then
last week I was telling Jocko that
Dwayne Johnson The Rock likes to work
out to its reigning men and he couldn't
see that so as the most workoutable man
on our show with the biggest guns
could you work out to a training man do
you work out to it's raining man sorry I
have worked out to It's Raining Men I
have worked out it's raining men because
we had to learn when I so we need to do
it we need to do standards and practice
breathalyzer test on this one I know
when we when we rehearse the songs it's
literally like we're like two weeks
ahead usually yes so sometimes three I
don't remember anything we did until we
actually come in the day of and then so
I work out in the morning as you know
and listen to the songs as I work out
what does that look like are you like
it's raining men no you don't do it
Hallelujah you don't do in Tempo no it's
funny because I'm listening to all this
random country stuff and 80s music I'm
working out and people see me I'm
looking all mean and serious does it get
you more pumped when you hear it's
raining men no Jocko it actually doesn't
but let's take a look at it let's take a
look at what we did here this is It's
Raining Men
oh yeah
[Music]
oh that's cool with the little tremolo
guitar
I bet that was not in the original
[Music]
all right well I want to get into this
while we have Lester here I don't know
how long he can stay because he has to
fly back to Nashville but um
it's a funny thing about Lester for some
reason he doesn't like playing Toms I
don't know he Associates like Hillsong
worship or whatever every time I ask him
like man break down the toms uh so he
kind of fought me on this I think this
is the last listen to all these Toms
here
maybe Lester's just trying to fight you
check it out who would win in the fight
[Music]
from the sound of that it sounds like my
man Lester likes the toms
[Music]
guys I don't remember any of this
get it Kelly
so I wanna I wanna I just wanna shout
out Lester here because this is what um
as as he said a lot of times by the time
we perform something we literally
haven't listened to it for probably two
to three weeks and we're trying to
remember everything and we have we have
Jazz r b country rap everything you can
imagine going on in our heads and this
is what a great drummer does and so
right here
um you know a lot of times live you
might have a one bar fill
if you go back and watch all the
kalioki's he's he's telling us with his
drums like here comes the bridge get
ready now and here we come into the
bridge and go and that's kind of what
happens right here in
back it up
[Music]
yeah so he's kind of our cheat sheet
when it comes to stuff but I would like
to ask I forget if we already talked
about this but do you know who wrote
that song
I honestly don't know this is gonna blow
your mind and somebody I had to scroll
back wait can I scroll back yeah Roger W
thank you I just double checked because
I wasn't sure if you were right but
Roger W brought the facts
it's somebody that you look up to that I
look up to yeah it's raining man and
he's been on TV and he has a shaved head
Richard Marx Phil Collins no Paul
Shaffer Paul schaff
I forgot about that yeah do you see the
genuine surprise on this man's face I'm
Blown Away Paul is Paul is one of my
heroes as you can see like and go back
all you kids like go watch the old
Letterman shows every 90 of what I do on
this show is based off of Paul Schaefer
he writes really cheesy Jingles the guy
can't really sing sorry Paul but he's an
amazing B3 player he's bald the whole
that's he's the offenders Paul Schaefer
well is it a different ball shaver
should we double check and he actually
he played he played amazing same one
keyboard solo and goodbye to you which
I'm trying to get Kelly to do
goodbye to you
the one that I was singing sorry Emily
is watching right now and reminding us
that we cannot randomly break out into
songs
oh
just like that so Lester uh real quick
before we get a book Paul Schaefer I've
been wanting that since season one like
I want Paul book Paul Shaffer do you
turn the switch that's true that's true
yeah please Paul come on I mean I just I
I picture the segment where Paul is like
telling me everything I'm doing wrong
and he like helps me out with Kelly
because he's like yeah so Dave and it's
anyway he he was an MD for all the great
species what if he showed up and he's
like I just look up to you Jason took
you out of time out
you can't keep me out of timeout all
right we're about to move on to our next
Kelly okay because Andy's like doing
tornadoes in the air but Lester why
don't you like playing Toms when I ask
you to play Toms
uh Jason that's not true I love playing
the toms
how come in rehearsals you always say no
I'm not going to do that I don't I don't
know what you're talking about uh he's
been very different on camera than he is
in real life all right so another one of
our favorite songs that came out in the
last two weeks I think was finesse by
Bruno Mars now we did finesse because
that was a kalioki Encore right because
Kelly was sick so we had to Pivot drip
an infinite pandemic pivot
pandemic and this actually ties into our
Deep dive
um because when I every time I think of
this song
um this is Vanessa's by Bruno Mars and
ironically do you know who wrote it
oh my gosh Paul Shaffer
anyway we're um
this is what I have to live with every
day on the show it's just amazing it's
amazing to get anything done in fact I
want to go back to Rachel back there
just back me up Rachel this is what we
deal with every day all right
uh so we did finesse uh we performed
this season one and back in 2020 and
when I was thinking about I was thinking
about the Christmas record When
Christmas Comes Around
we uh we went to Glenwood Studios close
to our show
and my my wife Rhonda who also manages
me uh she was the project manager on the
on the project and going back to Jazz we
had a jazz song I jazz is not my thing
it's just not I don't get it and so I'm
like we had a song called Last Christmas
that I had to produce and like who's who
would I love to watch play piano and I
reached out to Greg philanges who played
for Michael Jackson's TV one most
recorded keyboardist of all time and
his synth base
yeah a lot of funky [ __ ] oh
timeout oh my goodness this is our last
episode and we're like I mean we're
gonna get canceled now no choco all
right no more for that and so
why don't no I love jazz I don't it's
it's very difficult it's like a
it it feels like it's Alex
time out
I don't know I'll look at like I
remember I remember the first time that
we we were um we were gonna tour with
rebos Reb and Kelly and we came into
rehearsal and Reba bought her entire
band who are some of our best friends
and Kelly and we were coming together
and we were all gonna play on each
other's songs I remember walking into
the rehearsal room and her band was
playing walk away which is one of
Kelly's big hits
and it it was the most weird sounding
thing I've ever heard because they came
from minor country music and they were
interpreting it one way that's how I
feel about jazz like I feel like it's
almost insulting whenever I would rather
hire you feel like you're talking about
somebody playing the the genre and so
like listening to like the Reba band
interpretation to walk away probably
sounded as weird as whenever we tried to
play Fancy to them like it's just it's
in your blood and jazz is not it's just
not in my blood and so like give me an
80s song and we're there
so on this I hired Greg filling games
and that's that's one of the awesome
things about getting produced records is
I get to hire the people that are my
heroes that I want to work with
um so this is actually coming around to
why to finesse by Bruno Mars so we go in
the studio and the studio tells us
everybody that comes in here has to sign
an NDA our theme for the night a
non-disclosure agreement
and I'm a little bit panicking because
Rhonda has to call Greg philanges who
has played on literally more albums than
any other keyboard player in history and
Bruno Mars records well we didn't know
that at the time and so we we had to
call Greg and say hey we're gonna have
to have you sign a non-disclosure
agreement before you can even come to
the studio with us and he's like he
literally responded with
okay I'll sign it I probably actually
already played on this guy's record but
sure thing we come in so Greg shows up
at the studio he signs his NDA we walk
in we're working on the Christmas record
next door is Bruno Mars it's silk Sonic
working in the same studio and they were
they were working on leave the door open
that was I got a little fanboyish when
uh when I saw them cruising in just
walking with a cool strut yeah actually
parked in this parking spot and I got I
got I got booted just another little
side note when they won all the Grammys
for leave the door open and still suck
Sonic record uh I don't know if you
watch the Grammys but they were at the
tables wearing their 70s get up yeah and
they did this yeah
it was so good so Greg walks in he's
been a team player he signed his
non-disclosure agreement and then he
finds out who's next door and his Bruno
and I didn't know Bruno's real name and
Greg Phil and Gaines goes wait a minute
Peter Hernandez I'm like who's Peter
Hernandez he's like that's Bruno Peter
Hernandez that's who I signed this for I
just playing on his record it was one of
the most amazing things so
um but if I figure it out I want to show
uh oh yeah can we hear it uh we can
definitely hear it and maybe while we're
doing that I'll search for our little
picture but here's a little bit of
finesse uh anytime you get to have 80
cent sounds on modern pop with a little
bit of orchestra hits and some great
bgvs we're in
[Applause]
together
Ellie and the leopard print
we don't comment on wardrobe
[Music]
Lester that's like a straight up classic
drum look right yeah
it's like a take on poisoning
[Music]
are these on Kelly's friends that she's
dancing with
yeah
and shout out to Rachel that was amazed
amazing programming by Rachel there back
in season one and um and shout out to
Kelly's friends dancing with her and if
I can pull it up I don't
can't all right I can't share any
pictures I have some great pictures I'll
post from Instagram I have some pictures
from our day in the studio Jason we
gotta get this picture situation dialed
in we had a show where we did a lot of
pivoting today right Alex
I mean it's like wait can I do this no I
can't do this this is the worst anyway
great pictures you would love it if you
watch my home uh let's keep these
comments coming they're funny all right
what do you got
um somebody said Jocko LMAO that's not
funny what does that mean oh that's our
Alicia that's Alicia's LMAO and you
all right Emily save us uh Dan says one
day every band member should trade
positions we've we've actually done that
so somebody uh who was it that said that
that was Dan so Dan uh said we should
all switch instruments and we've
definitely done that before somebody
actually called that out we replayed it
recently and somebody noticed that y'all
were swapped and took a picture oh
there's a great day uh Kyle had an
emergency had to leave yeah he had a
Katy Perry show he had to get to so he
left real quick and left us stranded so
shout out Kyle and it was the best thing
that could happen because my dreams came
true
Jason said Jocko why don't you step up
to the drum chair and I said I've been
waiting for this moment to show Lester
up Jocko has one beat I started I start
swiveling my sticks between them what
does Taco's beat look like
I got a 70s Groove
all right all right let's move on what
are we doing today
I feel like so much more happened this
week too but it's just it's weird
walking right off stage right into this
can we show them our dance routine or no
still no they're going to tune in Monday
and they're gonna see it it's amazing I
really want everybody to see our dance
routine we actually worked very I
practiced more for this dance routine
than I practiced for any song Grammys or
otherwise in the past 20 years and I put
um blush on my cheeks or not not me but
the the Glam team of Valente shout out
to Valencia shout out to dancers they
have to think about lyrics and feet and
it was just the whole thing Earl the
Wardrobe was awesome we looked so Dapper
don't you think okay so another one of
our favorites from this week was I did
feel Dapper it was it was Dapper yeah
you looked handsome no it was I've never
worn one of those one of those sake
things they're like old people well
stockholders so they're they're socks
but back in the day I think there was no
such thing as elastic so you just had
like a clothing sheath yeah so then you
put like a little I've only seen those
in movies like when a center doing
something bad and he gets discovered
he's always wearing the little [ __ ]
things
sorry M Night Margarita says we're
losing viewers so she's Gonna Save Us
here oh no viewers come back never the
viewers are with you um but as a segue
to your next uh kalioki Andy not our
producing Andy Andy in the comments
Jason last time you promised us a
kaliuki classic but we haven't gotten it
did you mean the Christmas songs or did
you lie to us not only did that not me
first of all Andy
um
he's got no reply
yeah not only is it not the Christmas
ones but I today just now less than an
hour ago we performed a karaoke classic
not from a Christmas album from another
album of hers that is non-christmas what
album because I'm a man of my word I
keep my word which means we're also
gonna do the babies and we're gonna have
queso at some point
we're gonna have babies ah choco ugh all
right so yes we did a karaoke classic
um and it's coming up soon and it was
awesome
and actually it was awesome because on
tour it was a song that had no guitar on
it hmm
you know what I will say that is awesome
man first tour I came out on you did a
medley of songs you played piano with
Kelly's like five minutes straight and I
was like okay I'm gonna go to the
bathroom walk around well another one of
our favorites this week was
um from this album I got to produce a
song as well you played on it
um Aben Eubanks was a co-writer on it
shout out to a baby one of my favorite
people of all time uh we performed Santa
can't you hear me with Casey and Ariana
Grande and my wife and now she always
Ariana Grande is it Grande or grand
Grande is
Ariana Grande
Ariana Grande thank you she was amazing
on the song
and we're going to nerd out a bit here
there's only one I wish you could
actually see behind me um I don't know
if we can do it for clearance purposes
or not but one of my favorite artists of
all time is Bjork and Bjork is my muse I
think it's since we're talking about
pronunciations I think it's a silent B
It's Just Jerk It's Bjork sure oh my
gosh you're going to timeout for this
jerk anyway Bjork is my muse he she
inspires me every single day
well Bjork is one of the only other
female artists I know that records and
comps all of her own vocals when when I
heard that Ariana does that that's
really impressive yeah so what that
means from for the non-nerds but all the
Nerds are very excited uh so I recorded
I recorded and produced all of Kelly's
parts we send the files over to Ariana
she did not go into a studio did not
hire an engineer she records her own
vocals brings into logic takes all of
her best takes eqs it she literally
engineers and produces all of her own
vocals and sends it back uh that's
that's just amazing and I'm just I'm
just such a fan that's why
um you know all my staff are all female
there's not enough female programmers
producers engineers in the world there's
some amazing ones but we need more
anyway Ariana and Bjork Bjork comps all
her own vocals and as a Pro Tools genius
more vocalists should because
you'd know your voice so well it's a
personal thing why wouldn't you compet
yourself so not a little bit of a little
thing um to nerd into with Santa can't
you hear me I'm just going to confess um
Kelly wanted a wall of sound
and it is
every sound I think we could possibly
throw at ourselves
um to the point to where
um serbin
um who's that Google serbin
s-e-r-b-a-n uh mix engineer uh he's he's
probably mixed 90 of everything you've
heard on the radio for the past 20 years
starting back the Neptunes Gwen Stefani
no doubt Justin Timberlake Faith Hill I
never heard any of these people across
the board he's mixed all of Kelly's
albums and as a producer I send serbin
the mixes and I think
um well the very first mix I ever sent
to serve in
um well I can't remember what song it
was I remember he emailed me back and
was just like I like your drums he was
like dude this is you just sent me 140
tracks you can't send me that many
tracks so I learned over the years so
like pull things back submits if we
could go to nerdy Vibes too okay
um I have sent many tracks to pretty to
mixers as well and I've found that the
mix changes too much from as a producer
you're working on the song and you're
listening to it and you're kind of
mixing it as you go but then you send it
to a mixer and it takes on a whole new
character so I find that it's better to
send sub mixes of like just the drums
I've just I've learned that a lot from
Greg Kirsten and Jesse shotgun like I'm
learning a lot from producers in the
world but anyway this song I thought it
was in Santa can't you hear me I think I
sent sermon 250 something tracks there
was so much 250. I mean the vocals like
this thing is like
and when we built on that building that
was mine there's like 84 stacks of
vocals at some point so anyway it was it
was amazing and Ariana killed it and uh
let's just well here let's play a little
bit yeah let's check it but uh we
couldn't get her back on the show for
this one we if you want to see Kelly and
Ariana sing it go watch When Christmas
Comes Around the NBC Christmas special
oh uh Kelly took it on solo for our show
and on a recent voice performance and
you were there here's a little bit of it
[Music]
keep always lay rise
sorry Nancy in Nebraska I've I don't
actually watch these and I just saw
myself am I like toe stepping and
snapping or what's happening here
that's called the Holy Spirit I have
nothing to play so I'm gonna do this
well the singers are doing it
[Music]
that really tickled Lester
[Music]
I mean I wish like even that we we can't
isolate this stuff right now but just
that little I'm not gonna try to sing it
the sing it
if you want Jason to sing it let us know
in the comments hashtag Kelly after
party right here
[Music]
grief
Flawless you know what I wish you see
how they showed the uh background
singers there doing this beautiful map
if they were going meow meow because I
love cats that would be so cool
those are actually the singers playing
that's saying on the album so that's
Tiffany Brandon Jesse and then they Anna
who's at the voice they were amazing we
had four singers and they sound like a
freaking 84 piece choir because at times
they were
um
[Music]
did Robert Mix this one yeah Robert
makes this on the show so it sounds so
good it does shout out to Robert Venable
you're still great well now it's what
you've been waiting for hopefully this
is the uh this is the nerdiest nerdiest
nerdy do we have the sound effect yet no
we don't because we have enough time can
I play it for my phone yeah all right
we're gonna go into the deep dive soon
and I think chocolate has something for
us sorry did I email it or text it to
you oh my goodness so this is where like
we have special permissions like we're
gonna we're gonna go into we have all
the separate tracks of our performance
which you've seen now in the past two
Kelly After parties what's different on
this one is because I was because I
produced a song
um I'm gonna get to show you some things
that you've that that we haven't been
able to show before we're gonna actually
go in some of the multi-tracks from the
actual album and a little bit apart a
part of the process okay I'm trying to
kill time he can't find it go figure
tell the tell them joke oh my goodness
so this is Christmas isn't canceled by
Kelly and it's a deep dive I got to ride
this with Kelly and Jesse Collins and we
produced it Jaco played on it Lester
played on it Rachel did all the
programming Kyle played on it this is a
full team effort and our man our man
Luke Sullivan to Nashville played on it
and I gotta just shout out to Luke he is
so good at guitar yeah he did all the he
did all the tasty Parts I wouldn't say
tasty but fancy hmm
um that was the first time me and Luke
had ever actually hung out because so so
Luke has played with Kelly uh throughout
the years and and so have I and but we
never played at the same time so we got
to come together for this Christmas
session where I was wearing this
beautiful jacket okay so you all forgot
nobody forgot choco they were all
watching if we wanted okay I was
wondering if I should like flip it
around so that people could see Santa
the whole time cool Santa shades anyways
Luke's an amazing guitar player yes he
is
further Ado this is uh
well I don't want to get fully into it
because there's actually a couple of
cool things about this we've talked
about the writing process um with Kelly
and
um we didn't have enough time to
rehearse all the technical aspects of
this I'm literally directing and doing
all the things myself here with all
these parts but uh what I want to show
you is uh you know when it comes
I I talked about that a lot just on the
missing the Miss in the podcast
I would say that at least once every two
weeks I'm waking up at 2 am 4 AM 6 a.m
from a voice memo from Kelly Clarkson
and it's either notes about our next
karaoke or it's a song idea she has and
so I've always talked about these voice
memos that we get and they're kind of
they're in a different key they might be
out of time they're just ideas and
um so I just wanted to share this is I
only have audios I have no cool graphic
video to go with this Kelly that's too
late two four a.m it's she you can't you
can't put a time limit on creativity so
it happens all times of the day uh so so
Christmas isn't canceled I I kind of
wish we could play this first but I'm
hoping you've already heard the song by
now but this is really cool for me
because this is the first time you're
gonna hear the very the very very first
Inception of the song all the way to the
very very final I've never heard this
I'm so excited and so like fresh that's
so cool this is this is the first like I
think in music history I don't know so
it's here Alex just got excited did Alex
Duda producer of the show she's been
looking like we were train wrecking this
until now she's excited again yeah we're
like fine all right so can you saved it
Jason
let's see here's Kelly I'll be hanging
every light I find in this house what's
the context behind this you literally
woke up in the morning and she said I
got this idea she sent a she sent a song
such as she's had some ideas for it hey
wait we need to do a breathalyzer check
on you I think
yeah Jocko Nancy and Nebraska has been
very upset so here we have
something called
[Music]
epicus winter Wonderland's weren't made
for one so we've all been told since we
were young
okay so all you musicians producers what
I'm dealing with right now so Kelly she
hears all this in her head there's
already a Melody there's already parts
and so you you've all heard the song
already I've never heard the song at
this point so I'm trying to imagine I'm
just trying to figure out what's our
timing here
lost at first thinking that I might
because winter wonderlands weren't made
for one so we've all been told since we
now like What's Happening Here
but I'm not feeling incomplete
turns out I don't need a thing
underneath my tree
all right it's so wild because she's
going so like she's swinging the beat
yeah she's thinking I'm singing it very
straight so the very first time I
produced it I thought maybe she was
making a mistake and I'm like okay
because Kelly Clarkson doesn't make
mistakes
and then the courses
it changes so I I thought maybe she was
thinking wrong so I produced it up sent
it back to her and she was like and she
said no you're thinking she's like no
yeah Jason so then she sends me now
she's banging on her piano she's trying
to give me an idea of a beat here
I'll be hanging every light I find in
this house playing Christmas music so
loud so that's how the process starts
and then I would try to figure out a key
around it figure out some chords do a
very basic little thing and then I send
that to uh send us the band we chart it
out we go in the studio together and we
work on it and it was fun but what I
want to one thing that's so cool yeah it
was pretty awesome that was the the
original seat of the song yeah that was
the very first thing I ever heard oh
yeah [ __ ] and then you know and then I
worked on it there was no bridge at the
time I had some ideas and then like this
goes on and on and on and then she sends
me an idea okay so I have this idea for
the bridge for the Christmas isn't
canceled song and I know you said you
had one too so this could be shite um
I'm just throwing this out because shite
we're working on it um but
um anyway it would go it's kind of
um hard because the the backgrounds when
I say Christmas it'll be like Christmas
so they're holding it out underneath
while I'm seeing the other part but you
get that okay so it'll be sort of like
um uh Christmas isn't canceled that's
just you Christmas Without You with
stuff so I show you this straight again
I'm just bragging on our boss not only
what do we I think right now I don't
notice that I think we have like four or
five songs in the top 100 right now for
Christmas I have no idea which is
amazing all I know is we went to
Universal Studios shout out to Universal
Studios the other night they played it
everywhere yeah it was too much and what
people don't and and a lot of a lot of
our musicians producers have this idea
that you know you know this room this
this process where you go in the room
and you write and people help craft
things you can hear right here Kelly had
all this in her head it's all it it's
you know it's almost embarrassing when I
get a co-writer credit I mean don't take
it away Kelly I love my co-writer
credits but it's almost embarrassing
it's all there she hears it all and
we'll be in the studio recording and
I'll I'll play a chord and she'll say
that's the wrong chord and I'm like
based on what because I can't you know
I'll have this one note and she she
hears it all in her head so I say that's
a major shout out one and then really
impressive and then the other piece of
magic
um oh man I know we're rambling on but
this is the last show of the year so who
knows we're doing another one it's so
good everybody knows that I've had the
privilege I mean I've been able to
produce I'm a producer all Ever Wanted
and we had to catch my breath and like I
love pop music
yeah I drop names and all my hits just
kidding
I my wife will kill you I hate producing
pop music because I mean to be honest
I'm because of the labels right no it's
because I'm I'm what how old am I now
anyway I'm old I'm 48. am I 40 yeah I'm
22. okay and I it's hard to chase things
all the time things are changing so much
but to produce Christmas things like
there's no pressure there's no anything
you just get to have a feeling and a
Vibe so I love producing Christmas stuff
and the biggest thing I also sorry to
interrupt again but you were doing a
Phil Spector type of sound on a lot of
these songs and that's so fun it's a
it's classic yeah and now we're in
classic Studios with classic full bands
two guitar players two well one bass
player two drummers at times full
Orchestra the whole thing it's so
awesome I I love it you can throw
everything at it it's so authentic and
so one thing I wanted to share and we're
taking a long time to get here and so
you know
um you can fast forward or tune out but
this is I'm excited but this is the
stuff I love this is uh this is in the
studio listening to the live Orchestra
this is as they're recording Chris
where'd you record the orchestra
uh in L.A yeah this was that I think it
was at uh Warner Brothers Studios or
Sony I don't know it must have been so
magical just yeah hearing that that
feels like the real deal right yeah at
the at the risk of eyes glossing over in
the back of the room I'll do another
Christmas tie-in uh there's a composer
Joe trappanezi
um shout out to Joe yeah he's he's he's
conducted the orchestra and arranged for
Kelly's last two or three albums and the
very first time it was actually Greg
Kirsten that hired him for Wrapped in
Red I haven't I didn't heard of him and
we were doing would you say that I'm
wrapped in red oh my goodness Taco
you're the worst anyway we were doing a
Christmas special for NBC uh and my wife
was a project manager for that as well
and shout out to Rhonda and the the I
was supposed to meet with the conductor
and I've not had a lot of great
experiences with conductors like the one
time that we played we played for
President Obama in the Supreme Court at
Ford's Theater with Kelly I wasn't there
I'm jealous I was a guy that like did
the Rocky movie and what I don't read
sheet music and Kelly wanted to make a
change and so he like pops out this big
score scores apart I don't have good
history with conductors it was it was it
was a horrible experience Kelly wanted
to make a change so because of that I
asked Rhonda I'm like hey this conductor
is coming to the Kelly show can you like
go meet him and run interference out in
the lobby and just keep him away from me
for a while yeah yeah and so she goes
and meets Joe trappinessie anyway turns
out Joe produced all the strings and
Arrangements on my favorite album All
Time M83 Hurry Up We're Dreaming
Tron Legacy Soundtrack is amazing so
this is Joe uh we send the tracks to Joe
once I decipher what Kelly's doing and
this is the orchestra being recorded
holy [ __ ] that's so cool
now that is a straight up Christmas
miracle there's Joe
that's Joe conducting
the man with the mask we did this during
the pandemic
[Music]
Lester do you think he's getting in the
gym
[Music]
all right well let's let's get into this
track right here I'm gonna pull up our
little uh our this is a logic you're
hopefully we're all starting to learn
how awesome logic is this is what the
pros work in not Pro Tools it's Lester
shaking his fingernails can we put him
in a Timeout yeah unless there's our
little approaches Lester getting the
time out
hahaha
so I'm going to drag this out and we're
gonna we're gonna get to Kelly
eventually but one of the first things
at the top of the song
um when when Kelly was referencing she
won her wallet sound and I was I was
going through and doing a lot of
research what's a wall of sound uh Phil
Spector came up with it and it's just I
don't I don't know the definition it's
just every instrument is covering every
part all the time like it's like you
have guitar part being played by bells
and strings and keyboards so essentially
every sound you can throw at it it's
it's making a literal wall of sound it's
just you you can't have any space no
it's every everything's going at it
which you'll hear when we break this
down
oh it's happening again this is my
little uh oh I can't use my hands sorry
Rhonda
um you can use your hands when I do that
oh it's not gonna happen again okay
that's like the chair fart thing you
know I was doing some research and
Marvin Gaye What's Going On they had
this little breakdown section where the
guys were kind of having making a little
party Vibe yeah so we thought for
Christmas isn't canceled we'd make our
own little party Vibe and so that's
Jocko at the very top and it's Jocko me
Lester and Kyle kelly didn't even know
it was me yeah
yeah so let me see if I can find this
here I think it was
and she was like oh that's blah blah I
was like nope
oh yeah baby
and the track is called Help me find it
here Christmas isn't canceled well I
know that part but the uh the little
beachy part is called a wallet it's
called Jocko oh yeah baby
oh here it is
oh yeah can you crank that up it sounded
so quiet
so that's all going on underneath the
top of the track here I've played that's
probably about what six of us around a
mic doing it over and over so it sounds
a little bit like
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so before I play the the Kelly okay from
the show I just want to play a little
bit of the album parts so this is
actually from the album now I'm nervous
Lester did two sets of drums
yeah Lester Lester you're pretty funky
and then we all clapped in real life
oh we're not as funky
[Laughter]
now if you have your headphones at home
you'll hear that we actually track this
live as a band because you can hear in
Lester's drum mics here's my B3 playing
foreign
[Music]
the base on that kick drum sounds so
nice
let's bring in the base so we had two
tracks of Base going we had electric
bass Kyle
oh that pick tone
I I I can't say for sure but I would
imagine he's using an epiphone Jack
Cassidy hollow body base because that is
a classic bass sound right there and for
some reason I don't think my screen is
working is that what you're trying to
tell me where they're ending
hmm while this is playing real quick I'm
gonna try to do a quick
[Music]
dang Kyle's funky too would you say that
Kyle and lesser are two funky
[ __ ]
Jaco
B don't ruin our after party
all right don't know why it's not like
I'm talking about Phil Spector shooting
people
all right well here we're gonna move on
to a little bit
yeah
so let's go to the Kelly okay here
here's the Deep dive from the actual
performance
uh oh
Cali Kimball our our version of
standards and practices says I have to
put money in the swear jar
[Applause]
[Music]
I was right about the bass it's a
Epiphone Jack Cassidy
[Music]
ruin it
those singers look so beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I like Kelly's Blue Dress Oh wait we're
not allowed to talk about wardrobe
[Music]
all right so that's great I just I just
want to showcase what's going on with
the orchestra behind it I wish we could
do an orchestra only version of this
this is what's happening behind all of
the that I'll keep Kelly going in there
but
[Music]
let's pull Kelly back in there
[Music]
wow this is gorgeous why does we have a
band at all
[Music]
that's so magical yeah sorry I wasn't I
wasn't gonna solo her vocal this early
in the night no you're gonna do it it's
just like look at her face she's not
even okay just watch her neck there's no
muscle strain going on she's just
throwing out
and all of a sudden Christmas
foreign
[Music]
ER because it's so loud at that
microphone no I love what Lester does
thank you Jason so I do want to draw
like this Kelly Kimball has brought a
swear jar for me yes please
actually this could the problem is I has
no money this could raise the budget we
need to keep the show going as if Taco
keeps swearing we get our little budget
here get a little square integration
going on here
but just just to go back a minute to the
to Kelly riding and sending this
you hear the song it's very straight
here
but you
[Applause]
sure
now we're swinging
[Music]
so with that in mind let's let's Jason
you look so sharp can we just zoom in on
you okay so let's listen to what
Lester's doing right now
so since I've only sweared once I only
have to put one dollar in right
[Music]
so then we do at the end we go back to
straight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas is a cancer so I'm curious
Lester I don't I mean
pass Lester the mic are there
I can't think of other examples does
that happen a lot in music where you go
from straight to swing you have a better
repertoire than I do oh honestly I can't
think of anything right now especially
like the classic Christmas stuff yeah
you don't hear that because I remember
you arguing with me at a time you're
like that's wrong this is right yeah
right yeah
do you and Lester argue a lot no we have
this thing like there's a uh Lester's my
right-hand man so like as Jocko knows
sometimes I can't make it to rehearsals
because Alex needs to talk about very
important things and so I'll say
important yes I'll say Lester you've got
it and Lester kind of knows my formula
like there's three ways we start songs
I'm gonna test them what are the three
possible ways we can start a karaoke
so usually we have hits smiles smiles
yeah that's the first thing I got the
smile
yes all right correct uh sometimes it's
just uh a guitar intro or like some kind
of Sabrina Swampy
yeah swampy is not a people have been
saying that Swampy's not a way to
introduce yourself swampy is the way of
life in a song way of life uh the third
I don't know
um yeah do you know the third chapter of
course what were the first two nope all
right
we're gonna talk about this later Lester
yeah another time yeah anyway great I
mean this is so the great drums on this
song this is um
but I was noticing Lester on the multis
you actually played two different drum
kits so why is that well let's this is
Lester
drum kit a
which is doing this
holy crap do you do you like how I
avoided saying [ __ ] thank you
[Music]
the sub bass on that kick though is is
really incredible and then this is drum
kit B Lester
it's another dollar
so with those two different kits or why
were you
yes I was going for they talked about
the Phil Spector thing and I was also
going for the Motown thing which is kind
of tighter it was a smaller recording
room smaller Kick Drum so just a tighter
sound overall yeah when I was doing my
research some of the Motown albums
actually had two drum kits one like hard
pan right yep separate drum kick hard
pan left exactly one of my favorite
sounds I love that so cool
and let's talk about our um
I'm just going to Deep dive a little bit
more into this please this is what's
happening in Guitar now is this you or
is this Luke
sounds like Luke that sounds a little
more clean and okay oh yeah because I
was he's got that smooth it was tasteful
yes yes and Jaco plays the loud part
that's the part that's the part that you
can't hear so here's the choco parts
yep
that's such a Jocko part all right let's
hear it in the mix though can you hear
both parts
see this should have been the records
[Music]
I'd have to argue that this is better
than having the full production
[Music]
guitars only a little bit here's the
piano part
it now is is this a real piano or is
this a a software synthetic no that's a
real piano played it live grand piano
you got grand piano that sounds so good
was it Glenwood and then we did some
scents on top of it doing this
do you know what synth used nope
and then we add some Rachel stuff
uh what do you mean by Rachel stuff
Rachel does all my programming she's one
of the most amazing I mean she's
brilliant like this is these are Rachel
Parts here they're so good that it makes
me mad
whoa that's one of the coolest sounds
I've ever heard
no add Kelly in on this
[Music]
um
[Music]
let's talk about the bgvs so we were
recording in the studio and Jesse was
our vocal Ranger for this album she's so
good so many parts here's here's some of
the bgbs
that's all Jesse you can hear her voice
so so it's not Kelly on the background
vocals at all uh there's a few Kelly
bgvs but this is mostly Jesse and Nayana
and Tiffany
this is Miss might be Kelly
that sounds like Kelly
that's Kelly
Captain Jesse
[Music]
so when you're in the studio
um do you like double track that in that
like do you record it once and then do
it again and and put it on either
headphone side left and right depending
on the part sometimes I'll we'll do it
three or four times for each individual
Part Fort so you'll do two on each side
big stereo wall sound and then we add
more bgbs and we have
is this the part that's me and you no
hmm
[Music]
oh that's me and Lester Christmas isn't
canceled
[Music]
and so basically Jesse came up with that
entire hook we already had the song we
had the verse we had a chorus we had a
bridge and we just needed one more thing
and Jesse was like Chris sorry Jesse
Christmas isn't canceled and uh
Christmas Jesse wrote that so let's take
the out shout out to Jesse Collins so
let's listen to Alex right here
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
this is
holy [ __ ] that sounds so good check out
Lester right there that's just that's
stupid I'm tired of checking out Lester
[Music]
oh did you hear that guitar uh no we're
gonna hear Kelly right now check this
out hmm
foreign
[Music]
let's hear it by itself
[Music]
holy crap
I mean that that's like the standing oh
hands down you know the whole the whole
deal that's forces that's all I have to
say about that well the cool thing is to
summarize that is a [ __ ] wallet oh my
goodness Jaco it's a big [ __ ] wall of
sound all right well do we have any more
Yep do we have any more questions
help help my [ __ ] jail all right
we have a question I'm leaning one
producer's hard time for some uh I don't
have any money to give into them I was
looking on the screen it doesn't look
like we're shown so I was gonna show
that I am contributing to the jar let
the record show that Jocko has now added
four dollars to the swear jar
lers there's a big old fiber in here
sorry More Beautiful Things none of this
is my cash people producers and and and
people say Darren Langer our lighting
director is in the house and Felix takes
you what are you wearing right now I'm
feeling special what are you wearing I'm
feeling special this is
Mr Langer you like my jacket let's take
some fan questions while we're here what
do we have Emily smart all right I'm not
sure I'm Feeling Fabulous this is our
Christmas party we're gonna do some
quick q a uh to wrap up today's live uh
we have two more hours to go Jason
uh fraternal Pro wants to know how do
you decide to arrange something
acoustically versus a full band
Orchestra moment
are you talk uh so sorry so for the
Kelly o'keys on the show how do we
decide acoustically versus the full band
moment yes
um It's a combination of sometimes Kelly
gets directions she wants to do
something differently and wants it to be
more broken and intimate uh I would say
that's about 60 of the time
maybe 30 of the time uh we just have a
lot going on and I want to give the band
a break and um
I just feel like I much needed break
because the band's working so hard yes
I'm working hard all the time and uh and
sometimes we pivot last minute we talked
about last uh the last karaoke after
party uh sometimes we're rehearsing
while she's having her makeup done and
I'm trying to remember the piano part
and she hears that she goes oh that
would be awesome to do so sometimes it's
an accident but it always works out
works out well
what else do we have M Night Margarita
there's a lot of people that need to
know where both your and Jason's jackets
fashion sense come from you're well and
the jackets themselves
well I've already discussed this one at
length
this feels like a perfect time for me to
show you again this is cool Santa and it
is brought to you by our amazing Emmy
award-winning uh oh Destiny
breathalyzer check on chocolate
award-winning wardrobe person Earl yes
uh this jacket came from Express oh and
we have a good story about that we did
an Express Fashion Show last Christmas
and they actually
um it was it was um not to get too heavy
but it was my last Christmas while my
mother was alive and we had a song about
that right uh no last question
for that one
uh so uh so Express came in and dressed
us all up and we went home for the
holidays and I looked snazzy but this is
what they gave Jessie and I just put it
on and I thought I just felt really
special I ordered on the show first yeah
Jesse's like oh my jacket back oh my
gosh we have Jesse in the house
Jesse grabbed the mic that's Christmas I
gave you my jacket yeah you just missed
it we're just talking about we're
talking about you riding the hook for
Christmas isn't canceled yeah Jesse was
like there's not enough books in the
song it needs one more book
yeah that's saying Jesse what are you
drinking it looks so nice I feel nice in
this like I feel like you know right on
you yeah I feel like I should wear it
all the time yeah it doesn't look left
it looks perfect Good callback Paul
Shaffer would have worn this where's the
camera
quick q a do you know what song that
we've covered Paul Shaffer has written
a song that we cover that Paul shapes
the answer was It's Raining Men Paul
Schaefer wrote it Hallelujah yep it's
raining men yeah that was really
beautiful okay what do we have to see
what are you drinking
um something your mom made I'm pretty
sure oh Tina Tina you're talking about
Tina shout out to my mother Tino I'm
drinking tequila well can you get a
different cup and try our cocktail of
the week this is called the nightmarg
before Christmas and it is even though
we said Mark are you calling Tino
mostly
yeah anybody that doesn't care is
already turned off
I miss karako
how are you doing
[Music]
good are you watching the after party
you're on TV
can you give some advice here because I
know you love Jocko uh dearly but I
would love to keep on doing this for the
rest of the year and I feel like Jocko
is thwarting our chances by not playing
uh in the standards here so how can we
get Jocko to stop cussing
oh God I learned it from my mama
timeout is good
do you think it'd be better if he
leashed me like you did to me when I was
a kid what was Tina what is your
favorite what was your leash baby what
was your favorite Kelly okay that you've
seen Joko perform on in Four Seasons
like gotta be something that was solo me
and Kelly right
yeah when I was as long as Jason wasn't
in it wow he interrupts his mom too it's
just what he does I know he does yeah
it's just the way it is no when I was in
New York in the audience and watched him
yeah that was special that was um what
song was that
Tiny Dancer was it Barbra Streisand song
or like a oh it was it was um it was a
musical number it was from Zig Fields
Folly yes yeah yeah yeah well Mary Merry
Christmas Tina I love your son Jocko and
all the ways
all right merry Christmas love you Gino
this is why I don't sing
um
yeah make it a song make it a juicy one
well I liked this question from
Stephanie which was about a throwback to
the umbrella karaoke and she was super
curious if Rachel or you or anybody else
added a cuckoo clock sound I read that
on Twitter there's no cuckoo clock
sounds in umbrella it's a synth sound
that goes but it's not a cuckoo clock I
mean Rachel has put clock sounds on our
songs before but not an umbrella
yeah Rihanna yeah there's no cuckoo
clock songs I actually have to look it
up and go back to the original program
tough Taurus said Tina seems sweet she
is she's the best Little Mommy and then
Juliana dunno Yen said can we have a
Jason and jacobioki you're kinda gonna
get it soon when we dance well
somebody's asking for more for more
Jesse ISO vocals right now
yeah where were you
in a dream I'm really good that's ISO of
Jesse and me singing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do your part
[Applause]
well Saturday producer Andy do we have
any more to go or we any more questions
or we have one more fun question the one
more fun fact that we haven't actually
touched base on this episode was the
fact that you were actually nominated
for a Grammy for When Christmas Comes
Around for this hour that's amazing I
didn't know you could actually be
nominated for a Grammy in that category
but uh congratulations
all right we're all up for it we make
sure to finish your drink in celebration
I can't fantasy talk I have to go I have
to go pack tonight where are you going
for Christmas home oh yeah I'm going to
England tomorrow home for the holidays
for you is England you're English yes
all right thank you guys so much for
coming in we actually really enjoy this
I hope you find it as fun as we do it's
super fun but the thing is we're still
not Instagram verified no we're not so
whoever's out there watching can you
make that happen because it seems odd
yeah I'll pull up our little socials
right here there look at that you can
follow us yeah follow us at
jacquees.com and uh Jay season Halbert
season so merry Christmas happy holidays
and we'll be back hopefully in January
Merry Christmas to you Merry Christmas
to you and Jesse and to everyone out
there and producer
Margarita and Alex Duda and Kelly
Kimball we really do love you all and
this is so fun for us thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]